china asegura que dará respuestas
contundentes a la decisión de eeuu de no
enviar diplomáticos a beijing ante lo
que la casa blanca califica de abusos
contra los derechos humanos
washington no se opone a que los atletas
asistan a los juegos y les ofrece
completo respaldo el comité olímpico
internacional asegura que acepta la
decisión pero defiende su política de
diplomacia silenciosa
anderson pittsburgh at the work cientos
de personas que estaban en graves
aprietos en afganistán pudieron
encontrar una salida a su dramática
situación gracias a la diplomacia
silenciosa así que no la descartamos es
una herramienta muy poderosa y saberí
para world tour live and soul jinjin
estos desaciertos de eeuu han destruido
la base y la atmósfera del intercambio
deportivo entre los dos países y la
cooperación olímpica eeuu está dando un
tiro en el pie deberían reconocer las
consecuencias de sus errores
ahora la duda es si otras naciones
seguirán el boicot estadounidense